Welcome to lesson two.
In this lesson we talk more about
cultural differences between Dev and
Ops working groups.
We'll also focus on one
specific area of difficulty,
compatibility between development and
production environments.
>> As we've said before,
you can't solve cultural tensions just
by deploying some software tools.
But in this specific area, we can make
a big difference by making it much,
much easier for
people to build compatible environments.
The tool we use to do this
is called Packer, and
what it does is to build standard
deployment images that will work in both
production and development systems.